come
but today we're going to be learning how
to rock climb with very special people
so Garrick is somebody who's rock climbs
consistently first no damn reason now I
know you guys know that I'm scared of
[ __ ] Heights I'm not sure whose idea
this was
but I'm not excited to do this [ __ ] but
we have a couple of special guests we
have Sonny and Bonnie and also Garrick
who will be teaching me how to rock
climb or fight you go oh and that's
right and Ariel is coming too so guys
how long have you been out rock climbing
for um they've got like two years on and
off yeah two of the biggest mistakes of
his life Garret actually works for my
friend Dan I think he works also as a PA
a grip or whatever he could place him in
but he actually rock climbs he used to
do parkour too and just generally he's a
very fit and athletic man what I'm
saying he's the opposite of me and once
you tell people about your rock climbing
experience I fall this is Sonny by the
way I bought I bought my gear stuck in
the cool that's it Bonnie and Sonny are
two really close friends of Mariel I
think they actually went to college
together
Berklee back in the day and I actually
heard that Sonny rock climbs all the
time so I decided to invite them out as
well see what her skills are about not
sure if she's good or anything but [ __ ]
it have you rocked my before her ass my
girl Redman is right in front of me I
[ __ ] hit rock climbing I haven't done
it but I did it once before for a girl
that girl was a [ __ ] [ __ ] anyways I
never really liked her that's why I'm
with Muriel love you boo
rock climbing for me is like a mental
preparation I'm not sure physically I'm
not worried about it physically
it's just I'm scared of heights I got I
don't know why we're [ __ ] doing this
I don't know if I'm even gonna go up
there but personally I just think what's
gonna happen is I'm gonna be downstairs
and I'm gonna just cheer Mariel on go
baby
you know I know this is a very safe
sport but usually my bad luck Beach
safety in Hawaii I almost drowned four
times in safe waters because they told
me that was never gonna be waves their
[ __ ] those waves in a great white
shark well how the [ __ ] is that little
bungee cord going to support my weight
that makes no sense at all I'm
legitimately scared right now dude so
you're telling me that if I'm on top and
I fall off that thing is going to
prevent me from dying because I saw two
people that are probably 120 pounds each
and I understand there's enough traction
to help them from not falling I'm a lot
bigger than 120 pounds you what the
weird thing is like most guys they don't
want to look like a little [ __ ] in
front of their girlfriend I don't go
[ __ ] I don't have that oh if I'm a [ __ ]
I'm a [ __ ] I told her from the she's
been wanting to rock climb for a long
time and you don't like girls they
always like to sneak in what they want
by just kind of mention it casually hey
you know what'd be really fun if we go
rock Willy well [ __ ] you finally got
what you wanted huh as the climber
you're gonna say to me once we get
everything set in you're gonna say on
the leg long bullet yeah and then I'm
gonna check my belay device and make
sure everything's good all the ropes
look good and then obviously a fillet on
and then you say
climbing and then and then us like climb
on and then you begin you also there's
like this banter check this check that
exact you're okay go die yeah all right
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] somebody [ __ ] save
me okay so you're gonna go through this
hole underneath and you're gonna trace
this one back through see I would have
already died that's why you need a
professional around with you on all
times I would have just done one of
those shoot units that you do with your
shoelace so we're not yes
but here's what's the name of this night
it's called a David don't [ __ ] die
now and if you have an extra slack just
do a little a little knot on the end Oh
so if I ever wanted to kidnap somebody
and they couldn't escape I would use
this yeah I don't know who you are but I
could tell you I don't have any money
but what I do have are a particular set
of skills skills that make me a
nightmare for people like you you are
the person that's gonna keep me alive
yeah and the soft round
they want to do it I don't want do it I
didn't want to do it and you would the
weird thing I was kind of like just
testing my water I wanted to see if I
could just put a couple of you know
steps on there see what was happening
then you let me down again
I honestly Garrick is like what 100
pounds
how is he supposed to support me how
nope you know I'm a heavyset man if I
fell off that thinking I survived I
would have [ __ ] snapped a little
boy's legs but even more worse than that
if I were to fell I think I woulda just
went straight through the Earth's core
weights i'm 240 pounds near the solid
150 at most we are not we are nowhere
step of the way I think what would have
happened if I fell straight down and
Garrick was holding it in Carrick would
have fell and he was just shot right
through the roof you know those look in
season those anime cartoon where
somebody gets hit they just fly out to
the universe that's Garrick poorly shot
so scared
okay so this is the end of the episode
so I went up a few feet up in the air
just to test it out then I politely and
very manly asked Garrick to let me down
I was like yo dude let me down real
quick so I can reassess the situation
just like that oh I'm so scared about
what if I fell right now can we do a
test to see if you'll catch me if I let
go
are you a hundred percent sure oh god oh
he wanted me to trust him completely and
I did it I don't trust those skinny ass
oh my god why would you do this for fun
I had to put a scenario like you're up
there and if somebody is trying to like
assault you and I'm like I have to go
and save her
personally as I said earlier I'm not
scared of heights I actually enjoyed
thrill I actually like being scared
I enjoy being way up there I'm actually
part Superman so flying this stuff is
not an issue for me I don't think I was
okay good I'm gonna come down no you're
not because I'm sweating Oh
David you can do it David just step up
okay
Foley's extend your legs step up a web
soon realize that the second time I went
up there he was not gonna let me down
brother let me cook down my arms are
tired I don't remember what I was saying
but it was something along the lines of
me bartering or like trying to trade
something else in order for him to let
me down yeah yeah okay you don't give me
$1 I'll get you buddy
because he wasn't gonna do it I just had
to commit all the way and go up to
whatever point he wanted me to do it
just so I could come down
thank you done yep look ahead the only
thing I was thinking was the moment I
come down I'm gonna kill him I don't
even have a knife but I was going to
fashion a knife out of one of those
rocks and stab the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
that little [ __ ]
this is the sweat from the tiring it's
went from the fear was great great job
dude
oh dude and you do it I love this guy
that I saw Jesus and he was like my
child go down you can't do it and the
Garrett was like no I'm talking to Jesus
right now he's testing you I was like
dang Jesus really like that he goes yeah
like that and so I think you know how
most people had that feeling where if
they face their fears and they conquered
something they're like you know what I
did it I did it I'm proud I will I am
not scared anymore
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's not how I felt
at all what I felt was I want to kill
him but I'm so glad that I'm here on the
floor but I'm not gonna do it I think I
cried if you guys ever need rock
climbing lessons okay
call him up for a fee yeah he'll never
let you down I'll never let you down
literally and figuratively he will never
let you down
it's weird because I see all these kids
here and then just casually going up
like what idea to do drinking a little
Capri Sun but hey guys what's going on
look at that fat guy up there he can't
stop screaming she took what too big is
[ __ ] everything was I think it took
me a solid 45 minutes to get to the top
and then the funny thing is I saw Mariel
do it and I think the average person
takes roughly about 30 seconds did not
really expect because I was chilling and
I just looked over at the right shoe and
the guy goes hey go 30 seconds touch the
top she comes right back down all right
so are you like when like 10 times
faster David my turn
well David it was overcoming his peers
me and just I need this guy to catch
pieces you know if you guys want to get
as good as Jarek you got to go through
my lessons don't look at any of the
previous clips past this point here
Vince goes camera man extraordinaire he
don't give a [ __ ] about nothing look at
him like he's been doing it for years if
you guys don't know Vince used to rob
houses all the time which is why he
knows how to climb buildings look at him
this degenerate that's not the bad stuff
here we have Bonnie on the orange
thingies as she extends her legs brings
our left and right arm up she is smiling
as she doesn't look at that beautiful
red hair it looks like red saucer there
you go licorice hair you go down come
sunny
repelling as fast as she ever could well
my dear how did that feel there she is
there she is why the [ __ ] is sunny so
good at that she makes notes you know
what I think it is it definitely has to
do with weight sunny looks like she
weighs as much as a cigarette but this
is this is this is this is what she
weighs right here
that girl's [ __ ] good it is funny too
cuz she always she downplayed herself
she was like yeah you know like I
casually do it here and there
let me go spider-man I survived I
conquered my fear and we're gonna come
work
it has trying to be positive like [ __ ]
that it's funny because after we were
rock climbing for a little bit I
actually wanted to try it a little more
not saying so much that my fear of
heights is gone it's just that I trust
the mechanisms and I trust garrick a
little more so I wanted to do more but
then my forearms burn like a thousand
suns it's because I [ __ ] up you know
when you're scared your body is so tense
like my ass that like literally if I
wanted to [ __ ] at that moment it would
just it won't come out die knowing is
where you just do one explosive movement
and I kind of like a jump a leap to
another hold best insane funny
thumbs up good they're my favorite let
me go and try it dude there's no way I'm
gonna be able to do that this is gonna
try this out my pupil my protege so you
just got it is it how's it up there it's
just a round ball so just okay
I don't know how it's possible but Derek
just just soared through the air like a
[ __ ] Filipino Eagle just put on
pink scrap and rock a bug up that [ __ ]
was possible and I tried the dynoing
I think that was relatively close but to
be honest with you I'm a kind of a
deluded human being so what I see in my
head probably wasn't what it looked like
so this technique that we're looking at
right here is traditionally known as
stemming but what it's actually called
is stupid because it's fun
I've climbed many rocks before
specifically every night I climbed this
mountain called a rocky road
he'll [ __ ] look crazy how much weight
I lose how much fear I have conquered
I'm not doing that [ __ ] got a spreader
your legs all wide your [ __ ] ballsack
dangling like too little crazy [ __ ]
crazy bouldering and rock climbing stuff
has a lot of different categories
apparently there's something where you
just don't use your feet at all which is
by the way it's [ __ ] stupid I would
have done it but I don't want to
embarrass them because I'm so skilled
that's crazy
yeah
yeah basically what everybody found out
from rock climbing is that I am a master
rock climbing I have absolutely the best
skills obviously I'm deceptive I look
very fluffy but I'm very sturdy much
like a very old marshmallow well the
outer side gets crusted up the inside is
very soft
Maxon falling okay where am i driving
volume is tight you see right here push
towards you yeah
nice
perfect you just won a dance competition
I'm going to thread my [ __ ] leg
indeed this tiny thing here oh look at
that b-boy b-boy threads aka I man into
a [ __ ] sweater
as you guys already know I might have
already mentioned it previously in the
video that I'm extremely afraid of
heights and I know what you guys think
about being afraid of heights like you
get a little nervous and scared
no I'm talking about one time when I
went up on a hike and I just kind of
realized how high we were I got vertigo
and I actually kind of like nearly
collapsed passed out
that's how scared I am and the reason
why I mentioned this right now to you is
because living out loud and specifically
about you guys going out and trying out
new things I did a lot when I was
younger when I got busy with David so
comedy and I got busy with you know
trying to build this company work on
like go for broke apparel and a lot of
other things that you guys don't know
about I started losing that kind of
thirst for life and I want you guys to
follow it too I'm [ __ ] scared
shitless when I do these things and I
want you to experience life because
there's a lot more things out there that
you can experience aside from the
[ __ ] two feet that you look at when
you sit at home and you look at the
floor and you don't look at anything
else
put your head up experience everything
out there for yourself because you can
try and go on reddit you can try on go
on these websites to tell you how to
live your life and what things are dope
but if you don't actually do it it
doesn't mean a damn thing so remember go
outside and live out loud peace [ __ ]
that's good my phone one of the most
frightening experiences of my life I
have never done something